[Music]  took me 14 months but to know that Blake  Lively has a lot to celebrate after  shedding over sixty pounds since giving  birth to her and Ryan Reynolds second  child and son it just got me straight to  the jam we agree Emily Blunt the 30 year  old actress gets real with et about her  impressive weight loss journey at  Michael Kors fall 2018 collection  fashion show during New York Fashion  Week I just wanted to do it slow and  steady and you know and and so I did it  took me 14 months but and I think it's  important for moms to know that because  like it's also your thing that you like  one of the cons banks lookouts give you  a look after baby but like really  doesn't matter how many corsets you put  on it so how many people 61 over my  weight which is fine but it's also kids  change so much so if they change your  body and that's not a priority to get  back in shape that's awesome - it  doesn't have to be a priority but it was  for me